♪♪
Inspector:
Natalie Thompson!
(Click)
I know you've already been
asked,
but for the sake of the
camera,
are you sure you don't want
legal representation?
I don't need it.
I can tell you that you've been
arrested on suspicion of conspiracy to abduct Leo Newman.
No comment.
(Sigh)
Nope.
There's obviously been some sort
of misunderstanding.
We can't be certain whether
this is terrorist related,
politically motivated or simple extortion.
♪♪
Young guy, Leo Newman, gets
packed into a suitcase by a
masked gang.
♪♪
Scott:
NYPD flags four suspects.
♪♪
Interviewer:
Catherine Newman,
I cannot imagine what you're
going through at the moment.
I love my son.
And I want him back.
♪♪
We're being set up.
Sean:
Why us?
Aadesh:
I don't know why.
Sean:
What do we have in common?
Tara:
We're all British.
And we were all in New York on
the day Leo Newman was
kidnapped.
Do we look like kidnappers to
you?
Sean:
What does a kidnapper look
like?
♪You, you, you♪
You.
♪♪
Tara:
Without any proof of our
innocence,
Tara:
the damage is already done.
I can fix this.
♪♪
Tara:
You sure you know what you're
doing?
No, but I can't go back.
Catherine:
Nobody buys me as a mother.
♪♪
I'll always be a CEO first.
Executive:
Play along, there's no other
option.
First page in the playbook.
Except I don't remember the
chapter on the kidnap of your
only child.
♪♪
Interviewer:
You're being asked to
communicate in order to free your only child.
Interviewer:
These people want you to tell
the truth.
Aadesh:
We're getting deeper in.
There is still a chance that
people may understand everything
you've done until now.
♪♪
You have underestimated
these people right from the
beginning.
♪♪
Man:
The truth will come out.
♪♪